Emira squad you have the green light you  guys multiple hostels reported blue  blood purge confirm position  on my order  great speech speech  hostiles never saw my approach and  judging by her facial expression  neither did Turman Hey  you startled me your ugly mug has that  effect on me that hurts terminal now you  owe me an apology and a thank you thank  you for what  Hey that was a nasty flow purge see  blueblood appreciates me okay okay I'll  make sure you survive the next one deal  chimeras why we've been tipped off to  anna liam stockpile we will see if the  need arises our source indicates three  Phoenix operates the warehouse behind  the front company the surveillance of  the building suggests minimal assistance  HQ recommends breaching with explosives  on Western most wall  this is way bigger than anna liam  stockpot i will not hear the end of this  will i  Zoomer  [Music]  you